a strong testing regime plays a key role
in slowing the spread of covet 19
but getting tested can be a major
challenge
and then waiting for the results the
sample has to get to the lab and back
that can take up to four days that is
much too long to stop a pandemic
several nations are developing rapid
tests that turn out results within
minutes
but experts are concerned about their
accuracy
[Music]
well no one wants to be ushered into a
false sense of security thinking
they haven't got the coronavirus but are
spreading it
and it's a pain to think you do have it
when you don't and go to all the trouble
of total quarantine that's why these new
rapid tests could be a blessing
but could they also be a curse
as a journalist i meet quite a lot of
people and some of them
may be corona positive so today i want
to try out the new antigen test
hi there if you would again i would like
to buy an antigen
i'm afraid i can't sell you the test as
things stand
it can only be given out to medical
staff so you don't qualify
you can't test yourself you'll simply
have to go to the doctors
after this initial setback i find a
doctor who's willing to let me do the
test
myself not the standard procedure yet
this is the packet containing the
antigen quick test
i only got it a week ago so i had to
read the instructions too
there's also a small sterile swab here
if you can't put your tongue down far
enough you can use a stick to help
not that easy but for me definitely
doable
have you done both sides yes left and
right
afterwards the swab goes into a liquid
which is then dripped onto the test
one line means negative two means
positive
it's pretty clear the test is showing a
negative result
everyone should have a test like this at
home
it will be great for a mom for example
whose child wakes up feeling sniffly
but she isn't sure and is wondering
whether she can take the child to school
and go to work herself if patients had
access to a simple test they could do at
home
that would ease the pressure on doctors
and laboratories
and it would help a lot of people to
decide what to do
but critics say the test is not
sufficiently reliable
here's how laboratory and antigen tests
compare
when a person gets infected with covet
19 the virus load in the body starts off
low increasing rapidly in the first days
and then decreasing as time passes
a regular lab test can detect the virus
early on
with very little virus load the antigen
test can only detect the virus later
when the load is higher
so does that mean i could actually still
be positive despite having a negative
result
i asked a lab expert
if the viral load in the throat is not
high enough to be detectable by the test
that might result in a false negative
and it's the same if the swab is not
done
properly the antigen test is a cheap and
fast way of testing a lot of people
but the test is less sensitive than
others and can't completely
rule out an infection antigen tests
can't replace lab tests
but they can be a great help in the
fight against covet 19.
martin burke has been helping develop an
antigen-based test at the university of
illinois
he says it allows for fast and frequent
testing on a large scale and is safe
first of all how does it work
thanks yes to clarify the test that
we're currently using is a pcr-based
test a saliva test at the university of
illinois that was developed to skip
rna isolation so it's fast and scalable
results are within hours and i think
it's important to point out this is
different than the antigen test
we're working on antigen tests here we
have not rolled those out yet in the
laboratory
um is it also completely different to an
antibody test which would only
tell you if you've had an infection not
if you're
actually infectious correct
our test is looking for the virus in
your saliva so we look for three genes
from the virus
it's a quick direct from saliva to pcr
assay
so it allows us to detect whether the to
tell you the number of copies per
milliliter of the virus in your saliva
what makes it safe
so the key is that the level detection
is very low
so we pick up 500 to a thousand copies
per mill
we've been now testing about 50 000
people uh
twice per week over the course of the
last several months more than half a
million tests have been performed
and what we see is that people go from
negative negative negative and then when
they flip
positive we can see it at very low viral
votes so we think we can catch people
before they infect others so it sounds
extremely
accurate or precise how accurate would
you say it is
yeah it's very accurate we're looking at
three genes at the same time and for the
positive test we go ahead and repeat
them very quickly just to make sure
so we believe we have a very high level
of accuracy both for
positives and negatives which is
critical when applying on scale
with 50 000 people we can't have a lot
of false positives or false negatives
otherwise it's very difficult to make
the system work
exactly because false negatives are what
will implode any testing system
and and we've already seen examples in
countries where they've stocked up on
these rapid
test sets but they've been
antibody based tests and that's
basically backfired on them
well i think what we need to learn to do
is figure out how to use
each type of test in the right setting
right so this is a very challenging
problem
and we have to figure out the best way
to use different tests in different
situations
to maximize protection against spread in
a community
we think now that we have a system
working with the saliva based test
comparing that test directly to these
new antigen tests
head to head would be a really good way
to find out whether they could provide
the same level of protection
of the test that we're using martin i
guess the the question everyone's going
to be asking themselves is
is this going to be a game changer
i hope so and i think we need to figure
out
how to use the antigen tests so that we
are not giving ourselves a false
sense of security i think we have to
understand the limitations
every test has limitations and we just
need to i think better understand
when is the right time to use which test
and to understand the limitations so
that we don't give ourselves
a false sense of confidence the one
thing i would just say no matter what
test we're using
we have to wear masks and social
distance no
test will allow us to stop doing that
and that's really important
and the limitations in this case that
you need actual
trained personnel to conduct these tests
these aren't tests that one could do
just at home
correct our test is done in a laboratory
now the saliva collection is done in
tents you just walk through in five
minutes and dribble saliva into a tube
but then the rest of it is done
absolutely in a laboratory setting um
you mentioned this won't be the only
solution in fighting off the coronavirus
is it going to take other types of tests
and other approaches
to see that we do battle this battle off
this or fight off this pandemic
absolutely i think we need all hands on
deck and we need to continue to innovate
and find new ways to detect the virus
obviously we need a safe and very
effective vaccine
we continue to need better and better
treatments to make sure that people who
get sick
don't actually die or have long-term
sequelae in the hospital
and we all need to continue to do our
part obviously it's an extraordinary
challenging time we need to hang in
there and continue to be safe and make
smart choices about how we socialize
and wear masks and social distance it
works and we need to keep those
vigilant in place and before i let you
go
what sort of time scale are you or
timeline are you looking at because we
are now
heading into winter in the northern
hemisphere it's going to be a very
challenging time i expect absolutely so
we are in this for the long haul at the
university of illinois as i mentioned
uh we've now performed half a million
tests the last several months our
daily positivity rate is 0.24 percent
and but we are not letting our guard
down so we figure we're in this probably
for a couple years
and i think we all need to just kind of
adapt to the new normal
where we do very safe thoughtful things
to help us get back to thriving as a
as a society and as our economies need
to you know thrive as well so it's just
really important that we of course think
holistically that's my most important
message
it's got to be a holistic approach i
think in order for this to work
excellent
martin burke thanks for joining us today
thanks for having me on
derek williams turn to take the reins
now the science correspondent has been
busy looking
into your questions about the pandemic
what's dangerous is the pneumonia why
not find a cure
or treatment for the pneumonia instead
of the virus
pneumonia is a blanket term that's
generally defined
as a more or less serious inflammation
of tissue in in your air passages and or
your lungs
it can be caused by a number of
different pathogens both both viral
and bacterial the pneumonia that covet
19
can cause is generally initiated by the
virus and
can't be treated for example uh with
antibiotics
which only kill bacteria when they're
infected with saurus cove 2
the cells in the small sacks in your
lungs
where gas exchange occurs what are
called um
the alveoli begin to die and clog the
lungs up
and and that can eventually lead to
what's called acute
respiratory distress syndrome
as the pneumonia progresses the
situation can be exacerbated
by the immune system causing massive
inflammation
which is which is supposed to help get
the infection under control but which
can actually make things worse so so
treating
or curing coronavirus pneumonia means
either addressing the problem at its
root which is
the sars co2 infection itself or somehow
toning down the body's immune response
to it when it goes
over the top
[Music]
and now to the latest data from over 200
countries
which show new cases doubling in 26
nations
and increasing in another 83 countries
they've stayed at the same level in 10
countries
71 nations have seen their new positive
covert 19 cases
fall another 11 halving
and eight countries have reported no new
cases for four weeks in a row
here's the bar graph showing the
statistics of the last weeks
the fight against corona is over when
that whole chart turns blue
that's going to take a while